dr. Frieden I recall a piece in
Bloomberg Businessweek from a few weeks
back looking at how funding is allocated
throughout Florida and really on a
county-by-county basis some counties
spend quite a bit of money on mosquito
eradication some spend less of course
we've had Congress that stalled when it
comes to funding for fighting Zika how
much of a problem is that just the
allocation of funding to fight the
mosquito population in Florida the way
that it's constructed right now really
there's a short-term issue and a
longer-term issue in a short-term we
need to rebuild the mosquito control
infrastructure of this country and we
need to retool it for this type of
mosquito because the kind of tracking
and control measures are different for
this mosquito and other mosquitoes
that's really important for communities
throughout the u.s. in the longer term
we better ways to control mosquitoes
better tools better ways to combine the
tools that we have that's why robust
resources are so important so we can
have a robust response to protect
Americans against Zika and other
mosquito-borne threats dr. Frieden is
there any possibility of some kind of an
immunization or once somebody has Zika
to eradicate the the symptoms and any
effect before it actually reaches the
baby so we have no treatment for Zika
there are vaccines that are very shortly
going to be in trials that the National
Institutes of Health is working on and
that's promising but it'll probably be a
couple of years at best before they're
available that's why it's so important
that pregnant when women protect
themselves against mosquito bites not
travel to this area and we control
mosquitoes as effectively as possible
you're saying Winwood it's just a mile
of an area would you really be okay with
somebody traveling to the Greater Miami
area yes because there's no reason to
think that other parts of Miami are any
higher risk than any part of this other
us that has travelers from places with
Zika and the 80s a jip time mosquito
this one mile radius is actually a
buffer zone of about five flight paths
of the mosquito from the 150 yard or 500
foot area where all of the cases were
diagnosed